au Canada tout comme au Québec
d'ailleurs la majorité des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en agriculture
provient des animaux plus précisément de
leur digestion et de leur déjection mais
là aussi il y a moyen de s'améliorer
[Musique]
à Chesterville dans le centre du Québec
le paysage est tout en relief le village
est d'ailleurs surnommé la Petite Suisse
du Québec c'est justement de ce pays qui
est originaire Robert Rossier installé
ici depuis le milieu des années 90
puis c'est un peu à cause des collines
des Boissets montagneux on avait besoin
d'avoir un horizon qui s'arrête dans le
fond puis c'est ce qu'on a trouvé en
venant ici le producteur participe au
projet agricula qui vise entre autres à
faire un bilan carbone des fermes
avec 72 vaches en lactation l’empreinte
GES ici est complètement différente de
celle d'une ferme de grande culture sans
animaux pour mon entreprise mon musulman
plus gros poste c'est la fermentation
entérique la rumination des vaches les
vaches rumines puis autrement la gestion
des fumiers quand elle rumine les vaches
produisent de façon tout à fait
naturelle du méthane un gaz à effet de
serre au pouvoir réchauffant 28 fois
supérieur au CO2 et à l'autre bout leur
fumier qui se décompose produit lui
aussi du méthane et du protoxyde d'azote
un autre puissant gaz à effet de serre
pour à plusieurs niveaux
Sylvestre Delmotte a passé au Pen fin
les données de la ferme de Robert
Rossier l'entreprise
donc qui produit beaucoup de lait donc
c'est sûr que quand on calcule les
émissions par kilo de lait il est
avantagé par une forte productivité mais
il est aussi une alimentation qui fait
en sorte que ces vaches par kilos de les
produits vont avoir mettre un petit peu
moins qu'une ferme moyenne du sud du
Québec en général même si la gestion des
fumiers pèse dans le bilan de Robert
Rossier ça ferme se démarque comme dans
la majorité des exploitations laitières
on trouve ici une fausse à fumier
liquide dans sa gestion liquide il va
sortir son fumier de sa peau ça
plusieurs reprises durant l'été il va y
avoir moins d'émission que dans une
gestion plus classique où on viderait au
printemps et à l'automne par exemple
quand on vide complètement la fosse on
diminue de beaucoup les émissions de
méthane et une partie du fumier est sous
forme solide ce qui émet près de deux
fois moins de gaz à effet de serre que
le fumier liquide l'hiver
on voit qu'il est comme un peu plus noir
un peu il est déjà un petit peu composé
ou pâturage et que leur fumier soit
répandue naturellement aux champs ce qui
évite la période de stockage contribue
aussi à diminuer les émissions mais là
où la ferme de Monsieur réussi un petit
exploit c'est au chapitre de ces sols il
y a une autre particularité aussi dans
la ferme de Monsieur Rossier qu'on
retrouve pas partout au Québec c'est que
ces sols sont dans une dynamique où il
séquestre chaque année davantage de
carbone faut comprendre que ok au Québec
en général on cultive des sols qui a pas
si longtemps c'était des forêts dans une
forêt il y a beaucoup plus de carbone
dans le sol quand on met en culture on
vient mathématiquement relâcher du
carbone dans l'atmosphère cette
conversion vers l'agriculture et le
changement d'usage des terres a fait en
sorte que selon les régions du monde les
sols ont perdu de vin à 75% du carbone
qu'il contenait c'est la plus importante
source de gaz à effet de serre après la
combustion des énergies fossiles mais il
y a moyen de renverser la tendance
une fois dans l'atmosphère le carbone se
présente sous forme gazeuse dans le CO2
par la photosynthèse les plantes
arrivent à l'absorber et à relâcher de
l’oxygène le carbone est alors
emmagasiné sous forme solide dans les
tissus végétaux dans ces sols Robert
Rossier réussit à séquestrer du carbone
entre autres grâce à ceci de vastes
prairies de foin ça fait combien de
temps que ça a été implanté
annuelle comme le maïs le foin est
survit pendant plusieurs années et ici
l'agriculteur vient même ressemer ses
prairies avec un semoir spécial pour
améliorer leur productivité ce qui me
frappe c'est en fait la durée des
prairies sur cette ferme ci parce que au
Québec les prairies donc les plans de
frères qu'on récolte qu'on fauche en
général on va lui conserver quatre ans
ou 5 ans mais ici les prairies sont
conservés 10 ans puis elle demeure en
fait pendant 10 ans ça c'est quelque
chose qui m'impressionne beaucoup
plus on maintient une prairie longtemps
plus on accumule de carbone dans le sol
car pour survivre ces plantes
investissent dans leur racine
contrairement aux annuelles qui elles se
dépêchent de produire beaucoup de
graines avant l'automne au niveau du
carbone on va vraiment avoir une
différence dans la masse de Racine entre
les plantes pérennes puis les annuelles
donc si on détend les racines puis on
les pèse au niveau des plantes périnées
on va avoir en moyenne 13.5 tonnes de
matière sèche à lecteur dans les 30
premiers centimètres de sol les plantes
annuelles produisent en moyenne 3 tonnes
de matière sèches autrement dit la masse
racinaire des plantes pérennes est au
moins quatre fois plus importante que
celle des annuelles et cela se mesure
aussi en kilomètres le maïs par exemple
produit 75000 km de racine à l'hectare
contre 260 000 km pour les plantes qui
composent le foin cette masse reste là
est toujours en renouvellement donc à
chaque année on a une partie qui se
décompose qui retourne au sol ça peut
faire beaucoup beaucoup de carbone
cumulés toutes les années de la prairie
depuis les années 90 les superficies de
foin ont fondu au Québec au profit des
cultures annuelles le cheptelbovin a
diminué certes mais l'alimentation des
vaches laitières a changé elle aussi il
y a des producteurs qui ont donné de
plus en plus de mailles sans slash par
exemple ou de fourrage fait à partir de
culture annuelle puis ça des avantages à
certains égards mais c'est sûr que en
conséquence en cultive moins de plantes
terrines puis il faut pas négliger
l'impact que ça sur le stock de carbone
de nos sols
mais malgré toutes les bonnes pratiques
à la ferme de Robert Rossier le bilan
GES est clair la carbone neutralité dont
on entend tant parler n'est pas à portée
de main les émissions sont encore trop
importantes
[Musique]
la carbonate alité il y aura du travail
il y aura du travail
si on veut atteindre la carbonate ça
veut dire qu'il faut falloir d'une part
réduire énormément nos émissions et
aujourd'hui avec les connaissances qu'on
a il y a quand même une limite à ce
qu'on est capable de faire donc on peut
être un peu plus vertueux mais pas
nécessairement sans compromettre
d'autres objectifs comme de produits
pour nourrir les gens sans non plus
nécessairement affecter la rentabilité
économique de l'entreprise je pense que
produit que l'on crée que ça soit un
objet ou de la nourriture on a déjà une
activité humaine une activité
anthropique qui crée des gestes on peut
pas faire d'agriculture sans émettre
aucun gaz à effet de serre
faire un bilan carbone permet tout de
même d'entrevoir des pistes de réduction
une façon de diminuer les GES ici serait
de réduire le nombre d'animaux de
remplacement et donc la quantité
d'estomac qui produisent du méthane pour
90 vaches actuellement on a à peu près
35 à 40 ans qu'on élève par année puis
c'est trop à votre on a calculé qu'à 25
par année
en est correct mais en agriculture tout
n'entre pas nécessairement dans une
colonne de chiffres c'est pour ça aussi
que l'âge en arrière de nous on a des
vieilles vaches que elles sont à la
retraite dans le fond elle produisent
plus puis oui elle pollue mais on les
aime puis si on fait ce métier là c'est
parce qu'on aime nos animaux enfin
qu'elle resteront là
[Musique]
de mon point de vue il faut qu'on si on
le ramène à l'échelle de l'entreprise
agricole il faut que ça nous motive à
réduire les émissions qui est vraiment
je pense le l'outil qu'on a le plus
concret aujourd'hui pour agir vers la
carbone neutralité réduire les gaz à
effet de serre c'est bon pour le climat
et bien souvent cela rend aussi les
fermes plus résilientes
plus de carbone dans le sol veut dire un
sol en meilleure santé qui s'adapte
mieux aux sécheresses par exemple les
producteurs sont parmi les premières
personnes affectées par l'évolution du
climat et c'est pour ça que le projet
aussi émergé
de bouquins c'est des conditions qu'on
trouve à Port juste le 5 la veille on
avait des belles petites pluies d'été
millimètres
[Musique]
des sécheresses comme l'année passée
c'était un imaginable mais associé à ça
des gelées début juin ça c'est la vraie
vie des changements climatiques
j'ai producteur
une option des GES à la ferme mais face
à la nouvelle réalité climatique les
agriculteurs auront à faire des choix et
adapter leur entreprise et les nouvelles
connaissances feront partie de la
solution juste de s'informer puis
d'avoir accès à un bilan GES donc moi je
pense 50% du travail est déjà fait
[Musique]
cet automne le projet agriculum a reçu
du financement supplémentaire sans
nouvelle ferme pour en faire un bilan
carbone et être accompagné par les
chercheurs ce qui permettra de rendre ce
précieux savoir encore plus accessible